hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes movies TV art
and sometimes whole universes and makes
them Clash for our Amusement it's all in
good fun of course we're really just
here to celebrate the Pinnacle of craft
achievement and progress so why not you
know make it a little competitive
[Music]
I'm your host Mark Ellis and today
we'll have accomplished acting a-listers
both of whom have had to do some
on-screen tussling in roles like
International assassins curious teams
and even as two of the March sisters in
Little Women I gave it away right I mean
the title that vid did too it's Florence
Pugh taking on Saoirse Ronan right now
on versus in one corner we have Pugh
whose career in acting got jump started
with roles in the falling and Lady
Macbeth before being catapulted into the
stratosphere courtesy of midsomar Black
Widow and Little Women in the other
corner it's Ronan who I first saw as a
trained killer in training in Hannah and
then she went on to start a claim
projects like Brooklyn Lady Bird and
what's the last one with the little
women that's right as I desperately try
to evade Uncle joking that these little
women have forged big careers in
Tinseltown don't say that uh just go to
The Graphic here's how we'll determine a
winner round one box office round two
Tomato Meter slash audience score round
three iconic characters round four
memorable moments and then we'll do a
Wild Card round That Couldn't involve
anything from who can backstash the
relatives better to who might win in a
skills competition based around beating
up a host of baddies if you think black
widow's sister would take that one again
y'all gotta see Hannah but then again
Florence Pugh did many of her own stunts
in fighting with my family so there's
gonna be a good one sit back relax or
lean forward buckle up hop on the
elliptical whatever it takes for you to
prepare for an exhaustive look back on
two Stellar careers that will continue
to soar into the stratosphere for
decades to come it's Florence Pugh and
Saoirse Ronan right here right now not
physically they're not going to be here
they're in high demand and they're
probably somewhere else and very busy
I'll be here the whole time let's get it
on round one box office one of the most
refreshing aspects of this matchup that
we're going to be witnessing here is
that historically this round is won by
who's been in the most action comedy
comic book movie like Flix the ones that
first come to mind when one references
metaphorical blockbusting but here we
have two stars who made multiple hits
without all those perceived advantages
so if you thought Florence Pew flow Pew
that fly go do that don't say that was
easily going to take this round because
of her scene stealing turn as Elena and
black widow to quote Judas Priest you
got another thing coming but also Black
Widow is an MCU film and those tend to
make money as in
379 million dollars worldwide a total
that was no doubt undermined by a
pandemic that's still very good though
as is the take of smaller flicks like
fighting with my family at 41 million
dollars and the harrowing midsomar at 46
million bucks also on her resume is the
commuter which would end up hauling in
119 million dollars she's also released
a few bigger flicks on the small screen
with streamers like the outlaw King Lear
which I'm now being told are two
separate movies obviously there's no box
office data for either one of those but
here's some good news for really both
ladies they're starting out with 218
million dollars in seed money courtesy
of Little Women they may be little but
they make a big impact oh God I did it
again I'm so sorry but 200 million
dollars that's impressive sir Ronan
takes that dough and combines it with
her first big screen role in atonement
which would go under gross 129 million
dollars from there we generate more coin
with flicks like The Lovely Bones at 94
million dollars the host at 64 million
dollars and Hannah with 65 million
reasons to train your daughter where all
the human body pressure points are I
don't want to hurt anyone anymore in
more recent years Ronan has had Oscar
bait like ladybird transcend the art
houses and become a force of the
multiplex to the tune of 78 million
dollars and Mary Queen of Scots averaged
an additional 47 million dollars Little
Women still stands as her highest
grossing flick but in second place is a
strong showing for Wes Anderson with the
Grand Budapest hotels
163 million dollar haul see I told you
all it doesn't matter what type of
project these two are cast in or which
section of Blockbuster Video their films
end up qualifying for Ronan and pure
bona fide stars who proven that they can
be box office draws money is the end
name of my mercenary existence Pew has
the edge when it comes to highest
grossing single movie will that be
enough to push her over the top in our
opening phase well her box office total
is 811 million dollars which averages
out to a strong 135 million bones per
movie meanwhile ronan's average is 84
million dollars per flick but her
overall box office take is over a
billion bucks that's Blissful news to my
ears because now either way I can't go
wrong the glass is half full which also
means the glass is half empty so I'll
make the wrong decision regardless of
you know what I'm staying positive here
Florence Pew is already within Striking
Distance of Searcy ronan's career totals
and her average is already better and
for anyone who just says that's because
of Black Widow I'd say well yeah it
helped tremendously and for my movie
going dollar she was the best part of
that flick and might have been the
biggest reason for repeat business you
really do believe that Florence Pugh
takes the round from Ciro not that's not
going to work and she goes up one to
nothing thank you so much round two
Tomato Meter slash audience score oh
this is gonna be a tough one to eyeball
and predict because both ladies have
already forged careers that include
Oscar nominations and those films they
tend to do well in the old Tomato Meter
and audiences love a good crowd pleaser
so high marks are expected from Pew and
Ronan let's start with the veggies shall
we today the Clamato is strong with
Ronan and Pew because they're both in
that little women movie that Tomato
Meter is anything but tiny it's the last
one I promise the movie's at 95 so now
the question is this can either
performer top that gaudy numeral Ronan
Ken she's got a 99 for ladybird which by
my math is very very good Brooklyn also
exceeds the small ladies with a 97
percent Pew's best is tied with the
diminutive girls I think way too much
fun with little women at 95 but she gets
close with both fighting with my family
and the Little Drummer girls 93 plus
king lear's 90 31 I'm also going to toss
some points away for Hawkeye a show that
really picked up once Elena checks in
and that's at 92 percent even more so
than the 90s that Florence can brag
about I'm astounded that she has exactly
one rotten score so far in her
illustrious career it's shared by two
films malevolent and the commuter which
are fresh adjacent at 55 and may I also
remind you that the commuter Stars Liam
Neeson and like his 38th reimagining
have taken and it's still almost fresh
thank you Florence just come back Ronan
continues her fresh run with atonement
at 83 percent The Grand Budapest Hotel
at 92 percent and loving Vincent at 84
some of her lesser seen fare is
penalizing however as Lost River is at
30 percent Violet and Daisy is 22 and
Stockholm Pennsylvania is 27 which is
merely a commentary on the movie not the
town itself if they have an Applebee's
they're fresh in my book the lowest
rated flick for either star's Tomato
Meter is the host for Ronan despite
making a little bit of cash the film
failed to launch a y a franchise
petering out with just a 10 percent now
I will note that it did better on the
audience side of things notching a 49
that places it better than the commuter
where moviegoers saw just enough to get
it to 40 overall Little Women once again
Reigns Supreme on Florence Pugh's
audience score hovering at 92 percent
black widows right there at 91 improving
upon its 79 Tomato Meter number for
funsies Hawkeye is also at 91 shockingly
the only film that Ronan has in the
audience score 90s is Little Women from
there her next best effort is 87 for
Brooklyn 86 for loving Vincent and
there's the Grand Budapest Hotel
followed by 85 percent for ammonite
which begs the question where the hell
is Hannah
find me it's fresh which is good but not
enough to cause a seismic shift in the
numbers 71 percent of the Tomato Meter
66 with audiences and unfortunately for
Ronin it appears that too many of her
flicks have hit the fresh middle ground
that could end up hurting her overall
average Byzantium is 65 Mary Queen of
Scots is 62 percent and the way back is
74 and now I get to point out that no
she was not playing an alcoholic high
school basketball coach it's two
different movies with the same name not
to be confused with the summertime water
park dramedy the way way back and now we
come to a fun fact both the way way back
and the Ben Affleck the way back are
tied at 84 percent on the Tomato Meter
that is a stat worth derailing this
train for and don't worry Liam Neeson's
a passenger so we'll get back up and
running soon
now despite her rousing success in front
of the camera and Myriad critical
accomplishments somehow Ronan is only
carrying a 60 average on the Tomato
Meter and and a 59 average with the
audience score you know a sequel to
Hannah could really tip that into fresh
territory I'm just saying you can laugh
if you want to it's funny I know the
door is now open for Pew and predictably
she kicks it down her audience score
averages a fresh 66 percent and the
Tomato Meter hits even harder at 80
percent and just like that Pew wins the
round and goes up two to nothing and now
Ronan needs to respond I don't want your
opinion because I don't like you very
much so just don't talk to me anymore
thank you round three iconic characters
and sirsha has a chance here because
unlike those past two stages here we
don't care about middling box office or
divisive reactions we're just looking at
the best of the best starring TV's Eric
Roberts when it comes to who you played
and what emotions you conjured out of us
and with ronan's first feature film
being atonement she's off to a hot start
even brand new Schmo Mark Ellis really
dug this movie Once Upon a Time and in
particular the precocious turn from
Ronan she's a bit of a bratty child to
say the least but also in her own world
and misunderstood and going through a
bunch of crap from all the adults
surrounding her it was certainly a sign
of things to come okay can we get to
Hannah yet no okay I'll note that her
role as Susie salmon and The Lovely
Bones was also welcome and she forged a
bond with fellow only child Peter
Jackson who directed her in that film
and it also couldn't quite kick off a
franchise in between that 2009 movie and
2013's the host was Hannah yeah did you
guys see it Eric Bana is some sort of
assassin living off the grid and he
trains his daughter luckily named Hannah
to follow in his footsteps in case those
skills May suddenly become necessary in
her life she's such an ass kicker and a
serious adult kind of way like Kevin
McAllister's adorable in the Home Alone
movies but Hannah she ain't no wet
Bandit she'll take you out quick and
clean and hard just like the bees in my
girl
wait wait is it still too soon yes I'm
sorry Mack Florence Pio got her career
moving with the part of Abby in the
following and then it was playing
Elizabeth the Berg and the outlaw King
that got her more run and noticed with
viewers and then fighting with my family
happened director Stephen Merchant cast
her with the warning that he'd love for
her to do as much of the wrestling moves
as possible so she Dove right in working
closely with a personal trainer that she
still retains to this day and the
results speak for themselves hell they
don't speak they shout to the back row
from the ropes
as wrestling Idol page that's a tough
part to pull off because wrestling fans
are at the very least passionate about
their faves and for Pew to nail this
role speaks volumes about her abilities
and drive now go see her in Med somar
and tell me this woman won't go to any
length or climb any mountain for us
audiences it is not an easy watch or
re-watch and an earthquake really did
happen in the theater I was in during
the old folks
um ceremony in the middle of the movie
but man Jack and Florence really push
themselves in their roles as Outsiders
visiting a weird summer ritual and it
does have a lasting impact similarly
Ronan had to go to new places in terms
of emotionally and physical locations in
Brooklyn where her character had boy
named Ellis welcome to the club kid our
weekly family dinners are at Applebee's
e-money made the Bold trick from her
home stomping grounds of Ireland to
Brooklyn one of New York's finest
boroughs and wouldn't you know it she
falls in love you kids such dreamers
he's an Italian plumber who found the
princess without the help of mushroom
but she returns back home for a visit
and now Donald Gleason is in the picture
it's a multi-continent love triangle
that features more drama than the
basketball team in Brooklyn how is this
relevant and it resulted in a
well-earned Oscar nomination for Ronan
her second up to that point Oscar nod
number three came courtesy of ladybird a
riveting dramedy there's that word again
that sees Ronan looking for some
excitement Beyond her current existence
it's her senior year so she's doing her
best to navigate Life featuring her mom
played by Laurie Metcalf and love
including some fellow named Timothy
chalamet who would also show up in hit
those drums Little Women hello there yep
he's there and is brilliant in the role
as for Willy Wonka all right I'll give
it a shot and see Florence Pio and Ronan
are Transcendent Ronan is Joe one of the
older sisters and I hear a pretty good
author and Pew is the feisty Amy who one
time might have torched some of Joe's
writing so she was mad Ronan earned a
best lead actress nomination and
pugathan for best supporting actress
though neither one that night I expect
both to be a force at these fancy balls
for quite some time thank you as far as
puget's major proppers from me for being
such a standout even in a world is
inundated with ass kickers as the MCU is
her Elena is fierce funny and packs a
ton of emotion into every scene but over
the span of her entire career Circe
Ronan has had more of a breadth and
depth in terms of body of work that
proves she can do it all on the big
screen there's no losers in this round
but for me the most winiest is Ronan who
takes the stage and gets on the board
cutting Pugh's lead to two to one
round four memorable moments alright so
ronan's made it a ball game and her
incredible work dating all the way back
to atonement is the reason why but since
Florence Pugh's been on the scene she's
proven herself to not only be a
wonderful thespian but also a purveyor
of memorable sequences and iconic
moments can Ronan keep up as the kids
say OMG I just realized we get a Elena
Bulova versus Hannah matchup inside an
already compelling episode of versus ah
competition it's the gift that keeps on
giving
head up here and we can find out before
we get there remember how great I
claimed Pew was his real life wrestler
Paige now consider this due to
scheduling issues the production was
forced to film some of the Arena combat
scenes on Pew's third day of filming
imagine 20 000 screaming fans lining up
to see if you can convince us that
you're one of the most popular wrestlers
of your era and she did so with no
perceived fear or hesitation that's good
stuff we also see ronan's potential
early in atonement here's a friendly
reminder she's only in the First Act of
the movie but as a Young bryony Who
accuses her older sisters Beau of a
heinous act the ripple effect is felt
throughout the run time and it's a
credit to ronan's Ability she also
paired perfectly with Margot Robbie for
Mary Queen of Scots and in The Lovely
Bones the she's gone scene is the kind
of acting that gets you on the Academy's
radar of course she was already there
having been once nominated already Pugh
wins favor with us and Chris Pine in The
Outlaw King and moments like the power
speech she delivers in the I Choose You
segment Stand Out is why that's not to
be confused with Lisa Simpson's
Valentine's Day card to Ralph Wiggum
which said I choo choo choose you she
was just doing it to be nice Florence
Pew's motivation was far more meaningful
sorry Ralph you can actually pinpoint
the second when his heart rips in half
and Little Women both obviously have
their moments I love the I burned your
book part and Pew clearly embraced the
Brady role of Amy stating that she never
disliked her rather she enjoyed playing
a character that always spoke her mind
Ronan and director Greta Gerwig who had
already teamed up for ladybird once
again made a great pair in fact Legend
has it that Ronan went up to her pal
Greta at an award show and let her know
that the only role she wanted to play
was Joe and when you see the dance
between her and Laurie you'll understand
why oh yeah and ladybird is just
fantastic for the laughs you can't go
wrong with the there is no Tempest seen
outside of school you also get the car
jumping sequence and then the film wraps
up with an ending that may have been
sappy and lesser hands but with Ronan
and Gerwig and her directorial debut OS
a simple phone call expressing love to
Mom and tolerance for Sacramento is the
perfect send-off this round is going to
be tough you movies like mid somar and
Byzantium brought these experts to scary
new worlds full of weird cultists and
vampires but let's take a look back at
that Hannah Black Widow matchup the
movie's called Black Widow and Natasha
and Elena and their family have some
wonderful moments together I love the
comedy of Joanna mocking an entire
generation of characters who have to
show the flare when they jump in land
and the family reunion complete with Dad
squeezing back into a superhero costume
Rivals the clumps as far as dinner
comedy sequences go it still fits for
Hannah the prison escape may be your
go-to and it's worthy of that Crown but
I also love her running weeping and
evading to The Chemical Brothers musical
accompaniment that fight in the
container park is right up there with
Batman Begins and that sounds like a
great list for our expert researcher
Mark Hoffmeyer to put together the best
Container Park battles what do you got
maybe the losers Usual Suspects Hannah
is definitely in the top five and again
in the same way that ronan's extended
filmography might have hampered her
chances in the early rounds it's flexing
its muscle with more roles from which to
pull memorable moments from if you need
one more example I go back to Brooklyn
Kevin Durant Kyrie Irving sorry that's a
whole other thing
if you haven't seen the movie Brooklyn
yet prepare to be odd and that final
scene takes place on a boat and when a
young Irish woman is excited about going
to America Ronan replies to her with
it's a big place and that one sentence
fragment speaks volumes and intense pep
talk ensues and all of her emotions and
emotional restraint are storefront at
the same time storefrontings are
prominently displayed everybody with me
so far Ronan takes this round ties it at
two to two and I also like the movie
Crooklyn and now we move on you're on
fire thank you and now it's time for the
Wild Card round cultural impact this
will be the round that I most want a
do-over once I'm in my retirement home
the planet having already been overtaken
by apes or dinosaurs Skynet as long as
the robots keep my oxygen plugged in
I'll be thinking about is this too early
and Ronan and Pew's career to
prognosticate the impact they're going
to have well don't worry I hired a
psychic to join me but they couldn't
find parking which is weird because you
know your psychic so I'll have to rely
on the outstanding award show prowse
that has already welcomed these two
young Stars again Ronan has the upper
hand from a longevity standpoint but Pew
has already proven herself alongside
worthy veterans like her competition
today in Little Women remember both were
nominated for that movie but it was the
first one for Florence and the fourth
for Sierra Ronan and I pray that when
she finally does win it's not John
Travolta saying her name because that's
not gonna go well at all it's pronounced
circia it's spelled like sayeris so
he'll probably say something like
Slurpee but hey that guy could dance for
Sears should have such a pedigree and
resume already is truly remarkable
especially when you consider that you
never had formal training as an actor as
intimated earlier her lack of siblings
gave her a lot of free time all to
herself and that overactive imagination
went to work so once you started acting
it kind of felt like second nature for
pew at the ripe old age of six she
landed the role of Mary in a local
Nativity Play She gave the Holy virgin a
Yorkshire accent which made the audience
Giggle and she felt the thrill in having
captivated a crowd on the last day
submissions were accepted she tossed in
a tape to audition for the falling while
at school at Oxford and lo and behold
she landed the part amongst Pew's many
2B projects are the sequel to Dune the
next Christopher Nolan film Oppenheimer
and more immediately don't worry darling
meanwhile next up for Ronan is see how
they run a comedy thriller set in 1950s
London that acts as a who done it with
lots of comic relief so it's a thrillity
yeah I think I just invented that but
that's all in the future for the Here
and Now both talents have earned their
way into our hearts and into the elite
world of Hollywood a-lister but for all
of her incredible performances in a wide
variety of projects I'm leaning towards
Sierra Sharon and if only because she's
the second youngest four-time
oscar-nominated actress ever besides
movie trivia time think about it think
about it she trips it a lot of award
shows yet she's somehow great with a bow
and arrow I've always
for Lawrence she can play the winner
today's match which is Miss Ronan she
takes the round and thus wins this
edition of versus yet I can't escape
this vid without gushing a little more
about Florence Pew she can do it all
comedy action drama horror I mentioned
some of her upcoming movies but I saved
the best one for last she is entering
the world of Animation in the sequel to
Puss in Boots yes he's back he's got his
tiny little Sword and the little hat and
the booties all right compose yourself
Mark it's almost over farts will be
playing the role of Goldilocks whose
Three Bears are searching for the one
they call puss
cute I'm Mark Ellis reminding you that
the Tempest is not real thanks for
tuning in to this episode of versus hit
me up on social media at Mark Ellis live
and keep it right here at Rotten
Tomatoes for all the latest in the world
of TV movies and everything in between
have a great day and uh be good to your
monster
[Music]